we only worked out what that number is
can someone tell me what the whole
numbers I think we have special 23.92
not forgotten okay so that's the that's
the negative case right and when you do
the positive case 25:12 plus twelve
point seven dot dot okay now if we're
paying attention right at the beginning
you know that one of these answers
actually is not an answer right because
we we labored to it to work out like
what should we cut out we said the
biggest you're staying in four numbers
there's our smallest we can cut out as
one and the biggest square we could cut
out is ten by ten so in fact there is a
domain restriction on H that kind of
makes sense you can't make an
arbitrarily large rectangular prism out
over an equal piece of paper right so in
fact when I got to here right here okay
in fact you can even kind of see it here
do you see there's a domain restriction
implied by even without common sense you
just look at this equation right
remember one two three they almost to be
positive right because they're all
lengths okay well let's just have a look
at this time we'll H it's gonna be three
and zero I mean you already knew that
okay twenty take away 2h sorry I'm gonna
do this one first 30 take away 2h that's
also gonna be positive but when you go
ahead and solve that guy what happens
you go minus 2h is greater than minus 30
and then you divide by a negative number
which turns your inequality around right
so I've got one restriction from this
guy I've got another restriction excuse
me from this guy but I have one more I
want more notice this right so then I
say twenty ten great to H that also has
to be positive you solve it in exactly
the same way that you did before which
is like this and then you divide by a
negative number so I have three
restrictions I need to keep in mind okay
now just have a look at this one for a
second right do you see why he's
actually in this situation irrelevant
you see why he's irrelevant
he's not that picky right he'll accept
12 and 13 and 14 but he won't right so
even though this restriction is true it
doesn't end up mattering because this
one is if you like it's more strict
right it brings me in closer so when I
think about this one and this one and
this one
my actual domain restriction is zero is
10 yes we'll find out in a second okay
so all of that just to note right what
we just did I deliberately didn't do it
first so that you would get to here and
then sort of raise an eyebrow right
because if I did this at the get-go
number 1 like why did we why we say that
and number 2 you'd see straight away
without even thinking about it but now I
want to justify that's why this process
should come first
it should come first because then you
can exclude answers out of the picture
rather than test them in this find out I
am usually HSS than 15 but H is less
than 10 is more restrictive okay so if
you want to think about in this way if I
ever in my quad if I plot what would
these inequalities on a number line
right so for example I've got 0 here and
10 here and 15 here okay I'm gonna get
this one and this one and this one but I
actually want all of them at the same
time and the only region that satisfies
all three is I'm now actually gonna put
this on a number line cuz that's all I
want is your attempt that make sense
it's got all three overlapping okay
you see how what we're doing here breezy
and so much of what you've been thinking
about is just kind of implicit in the
question okay so I'm gonna say now that
I've established that but zero is less
than H is less than 10 this is meant to
be solution page right therefore H E is
three point months you thought thought
only that's the only actual solution
okay now as been sumit raised I think I
do
I found a stationary point I don't even
know if it's a turning point yet let
alone if it's a Maxima which is what I
actually want I mean we have we have
good reasons to guess that it's a Maxima
but we don't actually we haven't proven
that it is okay so you have a look at
the function that we've got I have two
ways to two methods for determining the
nature of a stationary point which would
you like to choose now my two choices
are my two choices our table of values
for the first derivative or test the
concavity with the second derivative
okay now which one you choose depends on
well is the second derivative hard if it
is okay just do this if the Secretariat
is easy then a table values takes a long
time now you look at this it's a
polynomial a polynomial is hard to
differentiate they're not there's no
questions no it is not even a product in
B okay let's do the second derivative
okay
d squared B on D H squared that's my
second derivative okay
I've still got that for hanging out the
front but now I just have to process
this sixth H takeaway I don't have to
take out another factor of two so at
this point sorry at this point I need to
find out what's happening with the
concavity so I say when H equals three
point nine two dot dot dot dot the
second derivative is equal to what
someone give me a couple of decimal
places
three times that sounds like it's in the
right ballpark
105.9 2x 5.3 depends on depends on how
many decimal places I use the whole
thing yeah okay so you you didn't
approximate you still use that value for
what it's worth remember what do I care
about you however it is actually better
is actually better because of errors
that get introduced to store this as a
variable because sometimes it will the
second derivative therefore is positive
or negative its negative in other words
it's concave down its concave down what
kind of maximum right but now I show you
tonight - yes what kind of Maxim is it a
maximum maximum okay sir I need to I
need to say therefore it's an action I
two questions there at the same time
which actually had the same answer the
first question was what happens if
you're Taeyang what happens if it's
sorry it's a relative bathroom now
do you know I pointed out it's relative
because we know what cubics look like
right they can go though or and then you
go higher okay so what I need to
establish is that not only is a relative
maximum but it's the actual maximum see
that okay now have a look I have a
domain restriction and it's a main
restriction
you can see for 0 and 10 what's going on
here right when you put in 0 what
happens it is it becomes all zeros right
now no I can't actually have the height
being 0 so I have to use this the limit
as H approaches 0 of the volume right
it's going to be 0 because this guy is
going to tend towards 0 you see that so
therefore that's not going to give me a
maximum right in the same way the limit
as H approaches 0 sorry H approaches 10
of the volume well have a look what
happens as you get to 10 this guy is
going to approach 0
do you see that this guy won't but this
guy will which in fact corresponds to
this length you'll see that when it
approaches 0 right so therefore it also
is zero so neither of those the
endpoints are not going to give me
maximum right if I can really say that
okay they cannot possibly be maximum
maximum because this is 0 and this is
gonna give me this is concave down
ok so therefore I can say all right
fantastic
I actually have an answer now therefore
H equals three point nine two dot dot
dot he's the absolute maximum
in a sense I could go home now because I
asked you know which of these is the
biggest okay I know my numbers are a bit
simplified but I guess it would be the
what is this this is one right this is
two this is three that must make this
one for ya
four minutes if did you do fall there
are a few Falls in there okay and you
can kind of almost like what is the
actual volume the actual volume and this
might be the question the question might
be find the maximum volume of the
rectangular prism you get you would say
take this number and you'd say the
maximum volume is I'm actually gonna
have to substitute this in right I'm f
I'm gonna have to go twenty minus two
times this number which is that what is
it 78 for something dot dot dot times 30
takeaway 7.8 for doctor thought times
oops
three point nine two dot dot dot okay
and I'm just for the sake of it just for
the sake of completeness can someone
give me a number maybe a couple of
disciplines would be enough
and we're dealing with centimeters cubed
okay which is like oh it's about a 1
liter milk up